president Trump addresses the corona
virus epidemic from the Oval Office
we will examine how we're all gonna die
then Bernie refuses to drop out of the
race a mathematically challenged New
York Times editorial board member
cries racism when people correct her and
aoc says it's racist not to eat lo mein
all that plus the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
big speech last night from the oval
office President Trump addressed the
nation on the coronavirus wuhan epidemic
and what the United States is going to
do it was mostly a normal address there
were some serious measures that were
that were brought up last night and of
course typically the left is furious
before we get into a question you got to
ask yourself what could Trump have done
that the left would have approved of
okay what actually is possible that they
would have said okay good job he's doing
great
probably not very much so we'll get into
the meat of it in just a second first
got to thank our friends over at
movement you know how much I love
movement it is now I think my favorite
underdog story in the whole world these
guys these two young entrepreneurs were
actually college dropouts then they
start this terrific you know company but
they're living on a tight budget you
know they're they they're living on it
they wanted to give a product for their
customers who were living on it so they
made these really really high quality
watches that did not break the bank if
you went into a store tried to buy a
movement watch a similar quality you'd
be paying like three four maybe five
hundred bucks what they were able to do
is get the price right down going
straight to you they've now sold almost
two million watches in over a hundred
and sixty countries by bringing quality
designs at fair prices I get so many
compliments on my movement watch I've
and I've had watches since I was eight
years old but I get them all the time
now they make sunglasses other
accessories perfect gifts for friends
family or your significant other in love
it's not one of these annoying watches
that interrupts your life with all these
gizmos and you know alarms going off get
15% off today great styling you get free
shipping free returns go to MVM t.com
slash knowles
movements launching new styles on this
site all the time check it out at
movement
MVM t.com MVM tea calm / knowles
enjoying the movement so president Trump
opens up his speech perfectly as you
would expect he says there is this
pandemic and we're going to take it very
seriously tonight I want to speak with
you about our nation's unprecedented
respond
to the corona virus outbreak that
started in China and is now spreading
throughout the world today the World
Health Organization officially announced
that this is a global pandemic okay now
I bet you could not figure out a way to
turn that into a terrible awful bigoted
speech right it's just what What did he
say it was the most basic that we got
this virus all right it started in China
but now it's all over the world and
we're taking it seriously and the World
Health Organization calls it a pandemic
how could you possibly pick that apart
well Jim Acosta on CNN certainly can
immediately before we get to the rest of
the speech Jim Acosta goes on CNN and
says you know the opening of that speech
sure was racist one point during this
address the president referred to the
corona virus as a quote foreign virus
that that I think was interesting
because as I was talking to sources
earlier this evening one of the points
that the president wanted to make
tonight wanted to get across to
Americans is that this virus did not
start here but that they're dealing with
it now why the president would go as far
as to describe it as a foreign virus
that is something we'll also be asking
questions about but it it should be
pointed out that Stephen Miller who is
an immigration hardliner who advises the
president is of one of his top domestic
policy advisors and speechwriters Wright
was a driving force in writing the
speech and I think it's going to spec
it's going to come across to a lot of
Americans as smacking of xenophobia to
use that kind of term in this speech
Chris xenophobia to mention where the
virus is from to mention what the name
of the virus is I don't know if they can
hear themselves it's the it's the wuhan
virus president why would President Roh
make a point of saying it's a foreign
virus because it is because it's true
you can't you know the whole point of
racism right if you say that's a racist
that's bigoted that's what is implied
there is that it's not true right that
it's it's unjust that it's wrong if
you're just making a Geographic fact if
you're just stating the obvious that
can't be
in a phobic or racist or whatever it's
just a fact and and moreover it's not
just Donald Trump who was doing it
schumak costume
made the same point back in at the end
of January January 23rd so not that one
month and a half ago he tweets out CNN
international authorities in Beijing
have canceled all large-scale Chinese
New Year celebrations in an effort to
contain the growing spread of Wuhan
coronavirus was it xenophobic when Jim
Acosta said exactly the same thing
probably not but it's just it sets the
tone for the night because no matter
what President Trump had said the CNN
people would have come on immediately
and said racist bigot terrible awful the
worst guy in the world so the big news
from this speech is that President Trump
is suspending all travel from Europe for
30 days this makes a lot of sense Europe
is getting smacked by this virus and in
particular Italy is getting smacked
hundreds of deaths they've quarantined
not just their economic powerhouse in
Milan and the northern region they've
now quarantined the entire country so
why does why does Trump have to cut off
travel from all of Europe rather than
just Italy this actually gets into a
nationalism question this actually gets
into much of what we've been talking
about with regard to globalization for
the last three years which is Europe
doesn't really have hard borders anymore
right Europe the EU is this kind of
federal entity where people get to go
freely from one country into the next
one and so if you've got this total
outbreak you know they haven't contained
it at all
in Italy then it's gonna be hard to
contain it within the rest of Europe
interesting about this travel ban the
United Kingdom is exempt so if you're in
the UK right now you can travel to the
United States still I guess this makes
sense right as of a month and a half ago
the UK is not part of Europe i sat down
on the verdict podcast that I host with
senator Cruz we sat down with Nigel
Farraj Nigel was so happy to talk about
all the benefits to it and have the
media constantly railing against brexit
well here's one of the benefits of
right you you can now travel to the
United States because you're not part of
Europe a good lesson on nationalism you
know that this whole this whole pandemic
teaches us a little something about
nationalism we were told by the
globalization side for decades that
there's no downside to globalization all
right there's no downside to open
borders let anybody come in or leave
whenever it's fine no big deal there's
no downside to outsourcing all of your
manufacturing to China now you just get
cheaper goods
everybody gets more money it's more
money in your pocket even if you lose
your job you know you'll still be paying
less for cheap Chinese goods so what's
the big deal
well the big deal is that if China is
the epicenter of a pandemic then it
might be a little difficult to get your
goods out of China right
if Italy had tightened its borders
sooner Italy might not be having this
problem you know we are now tightening
our borders under duress so funny you
know the the left has been railing on
Trump for trying to tighten border
security for the last three years
well now we're tightening it right now
you were not letting travelers in from
China
we're not letting travelers in from
Europe so we all agree we got to tighten
the border it's just maybe we should
have tightened it a little bit sooner
maybe the pandemic wouldn't be quite so
bad I also can't wait until the left
somehow twists Trump banning travel from
Europe to beat racism yeah that's that
they're always saying is they he only
wants to keep people out who look
different from us you know who who are
from Africa or the Middle East like well
what about Europe why are you gonna do
that he's gonna say is racist against
the Italians or something other than
that it was a totally normal oval office
speech given the circumstances you you
get the gist of it you know rah rah
we're America will rally together fear
not you've got nothing to fear but fear
itself the virus will not have a chance
against us no nation is more prepared or
more resilient than the United States we
have the best economy the most advanced
health care and the most talented
doctors scientists and researchers
anywhere in the world we are all in this
together we must put politics aside
stop the partisanship and unified
together as one nation and one family as
history has proven time and time again
Americans always rise to the challenge
and overcome adversity our future
remains brighter than anyone can imagine
acting with compassion and love we will
heal the sick care for those in need
help our fellow citizens and emerge from
this challenge stronger and more unified
than ever before god bless you and God
bless america
thank you great totally fine speech well
exactly what you would expect not just
of Trump but really of any president
we're gonna be fine we're gonna come
together we're taking all the steps
necessary you'll be safe calm down
please don't crash the markets right
that's pretty much all you had to do in
that speech and and he did it CNN's Don
Lemon furious apoplectic and it was so
funny because they brought on a
Republican quote on court they brought
on John Kasich to talk about it this is
one of trumps primary opponents he's a
liberal Republican so though I think
they figured he was just gonna trash
Trump and he would bounce off their
their criticism of the president
actually John Kasich didn't do that and
Don Lemon got even more angry want you
to go on and deflect and talk about
something else because we're here to
talk about the president's address and
and you said that someone else wrote it
he's the president even if something
should I know he did and he has to be
respond Don he put he put this thing out
because there was some confusion out
there okay and what look look I would
I'm trying to say to you Don we got to
move down the road looking back doesn't
get things fixed we're not looking back
the president's address address was to
night that is the newest occasion
tonight well dress I think it was fine
that's what I think
I love angry John Kasich it is just he's
so fed up with that he goes okay you
want me to say it I'll just say it done
I can't believe you're making me I think
president Trump's
Bres was fine I didn't want to have to
come on TV and compliment the president
but I thought it was fine when you've
got John Kasich complimenting President
Trump then you know really really the
address was perfectly fine what what
Don Lemon is talking about there is this
question of whether or not the
government is going to pay for treatment
of coronavirus or they're gonna pay for
tests of coronavirus or rather if the
government had gotten the insurance
companies to pay for that this is a
fairly minor point shows you a trump is
damned if he does and damned if he
doesn't when he banned travel from China
they attacked him for overreacting
then for a couple weeks they banned him
or they attacked him for under-reacting
Benny bans travel from Europe they
attack him for overreacting and there's
nothing the guy can do whatsoever and
there was a funny moment actually when
the address ended CNN accidentally left
the cameras rolling and so you got to
see President Trump's reaction at the
end of it I think watching CNN watching
all of the hysteria and the alarmism I
think he summed up what we were all
thinking okay okay
we we will come together we will come
together as Americans thank you god
bless america
okay what are we doing now that's
exactly how I feel we will get to the
big takeaway from we flew in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
core shield course today are like
computers on wheels that's what they are
right open up the hood try to figure
that out from electronically controlled
transmissions to touchscreen displays to
dozens of sensors and all this
technology we love it when it works but
it's very expensive to fix when it
breaks car shield has affordable
protection plans that can save you
thousands for a covered repair including
computers GPS electronics even more you
get to choose your favorite mechanic or
dealership to do the work and car shield
takes care of the rest I love this makes
me feel much safer in my car and much
safer in my wallet frankly they offer
complimentary 24/7 roadside assistance
and a rental car while yours is being
fixed it is just fabulous they've helped
over 1 million customers so check it out
today with rates as low as $99 a month
you have nothing to lose get covered by
car shield call 800 car 6000 and mention
code Noll scanner wles or visit car
shield calm and use code Knolls
to save 10% car shell calm code Knolls a
deductible may apply what's the big
takeaway big takeaway is whoo flu is
getting real the stock market is taking
a pounding they suspended trading again
today I mean we're we're now in a bear
market so meaning this market has turned
south people are very worried Warren
Buffett just came out by the way and
said you know this is a one-two punch to
the market the coronavirus and the Saudi
whale oil price war that we're in right
now but it's not even close to 2008 so
this might just be a temporary blip may
be an opportunity for investors to take
advantage but but maybe not we don't
know you know obviously the market is
pretty uncertain Tom Hanks now has lujan
virus that came out last night some NBA
player who I've never heard of has wuhan
virus the entire NBA has suspended
it's season there's actually now a
website called is it canceled yet
dot-com to figure out what has been
canceled because of one virus so far
they've got South by Southwest Pope
Francis's public appearances the Bernie
and Biden rallies and who was going to
go to those anybody like five people the
Google conference minecraft Festival
Coachella Harvard and Princeton and lots
of other schools canceling classes
telling kids to stay home they're gonna
do online teaching a conference about
coronavirus with canceled that was they
should have seen that one coming
that's that wasn't the Council on
Foreign Relations come on guys you set
yourselves up for that I would say also
by the way as long as we're canceling
things I just want to put my suggestion
out there I think in this time of great
pandemic the only responsible thing to
do would be to cancel the presidential
election and postpone it until maybe
like 2036 or maybe 20 40 that just that
would be responsible I think we got to
put partisanship aside here folks take
the public health really seriously and
postpone the presidential election by
about 16 or 20 years let's let's come
together America and let's let's get
this done as far as global pandemics go
worth keeping in mind I know that it's
very unpopular now to tell people to
become but this is not the bubonic
plague this is not SARS in terms of the
death rates not Ebola in terms of
melting your organs 32 people have died
so far in the United States it's not
good and the numbers gonna get higher so
no reason to be complacent
however compared to the 12,500 people
who died in the u.s. from swine flu so
far things are okay things are more
manageable to put 32 people have died
you know in two weeks or so two weeks or
a month maybe from coronavirus 90 people
die each day in the United States from
car accidents one person dies every 37
seconds from heart disease and the
average age of death from one virus is
Edie I am NOT saying that it's not a
pandemic I'm not saying we should
take precautions I'm simply saying that
people are not dropping like flies as I
think many in the media would have you
believe glad that the government and
people are taking this seriously
but there's a big difference between
taking things swiftly and seriously and
panicking there's no reason to panic
panicking doesn't do anybody any good
and I actually think there's a reason
that people panic that has nothing to do
with the wuhan virus which we'll get to
in just a little bit I've got to turn to
some political news Bernie Sanders after
getting shellacked by Joe Biden on the
second Super Tuesday is staying in the
race here is Bernie announcing why he's
got no intention of going anywhere
became even more apparent yesterday is
that while we are currently losing the
delegate count approximately 800
delegates for Joe Biden and 660 for us
we are strongly winning in two enormous
ly important areas which will determine
the future of our country
typical BS you hear this from these
Bolsheviks every single time actually
they're winning every time these
Bolsheviks including the original
Bolsheviks every time they would lose
they would say that they want and this
is true all the way up to modern leftist
politicians we may be losing but we're
secretly winning how are we secretly
winning Bernie you tell me says they
might not be winning in terms of that
delegates or the voters of those minor
issues but they're winning the
ideological debate strong majority of
the American people support our
progressive agenda while our campaign
has won the ideological debate we are
losing the debate over electability if
you are losing the debate over
electability which is to say if you are
losing the electoral battle then you are
losing the ideological debate if a large
majority of the American people support
Bernie Sanders is agenda then Bernie
Sanders would be winning
but he's not winning now what Bernie
might say is no it's about the
candidates too so they support what I
believe but they do not support Who I am
and my part of me Bernie Sanders
seventy-eight years old but they and
they do support Joe Biden's personality
but they don't support what he believes
that is not true how do I know that's
not true because just physically Bernie
and Biden are the same candidate they're
two white guys one is 77 and a half and
one is 78 they are all things being
equal right the only thing that differs
is their ideology and Biden is winning
and Bernie is losing they they insist on
it though the left constantly people
really believe what we're selling they
really like theirs just for some reason
there's one weird trick that explains
why we're not actually winning at the
polls Bernie Bernie has one excuse for
it he says he's winning among the young
voters he's winning the next generation
of Americans need to win the voters who
represent the future of our country and
you must speak to the issues of concern
to them you cannot simply be satisfied
by winning the votes of people who are
oldham but bernie is not winning the
youths and he's not winning the youths
cuz the youths aren't showing up so they
might tweet for you and they might go on
different message boards and say they
really like you but if they don't show
up to the polls then you're not winning
the youths the left always does this
they can't lose they're always winning
and the more left they are the more
certain they are that they are winning
Hillary Clinton she's secretly 1 2016
Stacey Abrams she's secretly the
governor of Georgia Al Gore a guy
secretly won the presidential election
just for some reason it looked like
George Bush won they insist they won
they insist they won rather even when
they lost the reason is they can't lose
they can't lose because they are the
future right they know what the future
is everything
Berni just said we are winning the
ideological battle the majority of
people support our ideology we're
winning the youths we're winning the
future you're not right you're obviously
not but you are so convinced you begin
with the premise that you are the future
and so you can't possibly lose any time
you lose something had to go wrong this
is the problem there are many problems
this is one of the problems with
progressivism with progress in
ideologies you are the future it's not
even a question we all know that for
certain the only question is are people
gonna rob you of bringing about the
future now are they gonna steal it from
you illegitimate Lee this is why when
leftists particularly hard leftists lose
elections it's always got to be a
legitimate it could simply not be the
case
that people have rejected their ideology
because their ideology is not merely a
political view among many it is the
science of the future and if people are
stopping the future from happening that
is wrong it's immoral it's unjust and
it's illegitimate that's the
philosophical basis for Bernie staying
in the PR basis is this is his last shot
and he wants to figure it out he wants
to just like finally get his ideology
over the finish line as long as he's got
breath in his lungs then there's a
practical basis which is that Joe Biden
might not make it I don't look I don't I
mean I when I say I'm not a good thing
he's gonna croak or something
necessarily I'm just saying he doesn't
have physical stamina he's now asking
for the next debate to have chairs so
that he doesn't have to stand up the
whole time okay he is not a vigorous man
and so right now I think what Bernie's
looking at is gosh if something takes
Joe Biden out of this race and I have
many many more delegates than I do right
now then it will be very hard for the
Democrats to steal it from me at the
convention it's a small chance that that
actually plays out in the end but I
think that's the practical basis Bernie
is thinking about turning our attention
to the news media you remember the other
day when Mara gay she's this New York
Times editorial board member she was on
the Brian Williams show on MSNBC and
they were talking about how Mike
Bloomberg had spent five hundred million
dollars on his campaign there's 320
million Americans
which means that Mike Bloomberg could
have instead of it running his campaign
just simply given each American 1
million dollars and they talked about
this without understanding how zeros
work how orders of magnitude work in
mathematics who they're actually with
the money he spent he could have given
every American a million dollar got it
let's put it up a screen it when I read
it tonight on social media it kind of
all became clear
Bloomberg spent five hundred million on
ads u.s. population 327 million don't
tell us if you're ahead of us on the
math he could have given each American
one million dollars and I've had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing it does it
does suggest you know what we're talking
about here which is there's too much
money in politics that's it that's what
it suggests right isn't it not at all
so some people called her ad for this
obviously and now do you think Morag a
New York Times editorial board member or
Brian Williams for that matter but Maura
Gay is the one who who has been
complaining about this do you think she
apologized corrected her mistake said
gosh you know I should think before I
speak I should figure out basic
mathematical concepts I rare-earth
medical concepts I should have a little
humility whoops
whoopsie my bad I'll get you next time
oh no she's complaining and she's crying
racism she's saying look I got mean
messages on email and on Twitter after I
made that comment
look it was racism and frankly I just
made a trivial math error that's her
direct quote reveal math error so I
guess that would be her second math
error because getting your figures off
by six orders of magnitude is not a
trivial math error
all right that's like it is a common
math error among leftists it's just yeah
million a billion what trillion it's all
it's all the same it ends in iliyan
right we'll spend all the money however
it's a pretty significant error also it
doesn't look good when you're a public
figure who complains about people being
mean to you
maura gay I have no doubt that she got
racist messages she probably did I don't
know that she got racist messages
because people hate black people I think
she got racist messages because people
don't like her and people don't like her
because she talks politics on TV and
everybody who talks politics on TV gets
vile vile messages a lot of them all the
time and what they do is they attack you
for various things look it happens to
everybody they'll attack you for the way
you look they'll attack you for the way
you talk they'll attack you for the way
your family and friends look they'll
attack for all these things right
however I think 99 times out of a
hundred that's not expressing some
deep-seated hatred for some category
that you might fall into they just don't
like you that's how people are mean
right that's how that's how people bully
you that's what the internet is all
right I'm not saying I enjoy that I
don't like getting mean messages but if
you are going to put yourself out on
national television and talk about
contentious issues you are going to have
to take some heat you're gonna have to
get some mean vile vicious unforgiveable
unsupportable indefensible messages that
goes with the territory and you can
either complain about that and play the
victim or you can say hey look I've got
a pretty prominent position I'm on the
New York Times editorial board I made an
egregious and hilarious mistake whoops
my bad maybe I'll sit sit out the next
few rounds and think think a little bit
more next time
certainly more gay cannot do that the
left in general can't do that before we
get into the mailbag aoc has some
comments on racism she wants you to know
that if you are so afraid of the wuhan
virus that you don't eat lo mein that
you're a racist honestly it sounds
almost so silly to say but there's a lot
of restaurants that are feeling the pain
of racism where people are literally not
patronage Chinese restaurants they're
not patron occasion restaurants because
of just straight-up
racism around the coronavirus they're
not patronym them all right and you
better not patron me and we certainly we
shouldn't patron each other I think the
word AOC was looking for was hate
but we'll just let that go free well you
know in the spirit of charity and
national unity we'll let that one slide
we will focus on the point that she's
making if you don't want to eat chicken
kung pao chicken
during Wuhan virus time that you're
somehow a racist it's not racist to
point out where a disease comes from
it's not racist to point out where the
epicenter of a global pandemic is okay
it wasn't racist to call the Spanish flu
the Spanish flu though probably all of
the woke people like aoc they want to
rename that like love latinx flu I don't
even know how to pronounce that word
where they go Latin X instead of Latino
and it latinx it's the Latisse flu all
right it's not racist to point out that
the Ebola virus comes from the Ebola
River it's not racist to refer to West
Nile virus right it's not all of these
different things actually there's some
evidence that it's just a part of
communist propaganda in China to
convince gullible idiot Westerners that
it's racist to point out that the virus
came from China we're getting some
evidence that it's actually a conscious
effort by the communications apparatus
of the Chinese government to convince
people of this and of course that
gullible
self-hating leftists in America just
eaten that whole hog why are you so
afraid of coronavirus that's the point I
want to leave on today before we get to
the mailbag why are you so afraid of it
I suspect it has something to do with
death it's you're afraid of dying right
nobody wants to die however at different
periods of time the fear of death has
ebbed and flowed you know people have
been much more intensely afraid of death
or much less afraid of death I think
that the fear of death in our culture
has gotten a lot worse I think the
evidence of this is all around us levels
of stress are going through the roof
anxiety is going through the roof
depression drugs going through the roof
this is especially true among young
people who are experiencing stress and
anxiety at a much higher rate you see it
even with kids now there was a BBC
survey that showed that that children
are having disturbed sleep
or getting eating disorders now because
they're so afraid of death from climate
change why are people so afraid of death
I have to imagine it has something to do
with the precipitous decline in
religiosity particularly among young
people I mean the the groups that are
experiencing the greatest religious
decline growing up without any kind of
religious worldview are the ones who are
most stressed and most anxious an
important takeaway from coronavirus you
are going to die I can guarantee you
that with 100% certainty you are going
to die coincidentally the coronavirus
scare that really took took hold
during the same time as lent you know at
the beginning of Lent is when Christians
get ashes on their forehead and you you
hear remember man you are dust and to
dust you shall return statistically
you're not going to die from the wuhan
virus also statistically you are going
to die
probably better when you think of that
instead of just running out to the store
and buying up all the toilet paper and
canned tomatoes that you possibly can
it's probably a better use of your time
to think ahead to that certainty that
will come alright let's get into the
mailbag but first I got to thank our
friends over at honey because if you are
going to go out to the store and buy up
every single thing maybe best during
these times to do it online
okay maybe best not to go outside and
you know just public health caution
honey can save you a lot of money when
you shop online it's the free online
shopping tool that automatically finds
the best promo codes applies them to
your cart you know how great it feels to
save right you know how you just think
okay that's free money I could have
worked a little longer or I could have
gotten that sweet sweet free money have
been using honey since before the daily
wire even existed you know it it just
feels great so it supports over 30,000
stores online that includes Macy's
includes Target Sephora Best Buy and
more they're adding more every day honey
has found it's over 18 million members
over two billion dollars in savings I
don't I wonder how much of that I got
personally because I use it all the time
using honey
great think of it as a little daily
victory plus it's free to use and
installs in just a few seconds get honey
for free at join honey calm slash
Knowles kena wles that's join honey calm
/ Knowles and right now we are offering
25% off all daily wire membership plans
when you use the coupon code never
socialist just like Joe Biden wanting to
take away your AR 14 we have got to take
away this deal so you're gonna want to
act fast because it goes away Friday at
midnight Pacific time at exactly the
same time when you can no longer enter
the United States from Europe
you also can't save 25% off your daily
wire membership using the coupon code
never socialist head on over to Daley
wire.com slash subscribe we'll be right
back with the mailbag
first question from Dave Michel if
Eric's wall well gets the coronavirus
does that mean we all have the
coronavirus it does this is through the
swell transitive property whereby Eric's
wall well is us we are Eric's wall well
and so if he goes we all go from Katie
hi Michel what would happen if Biden won
the nomination but his mental decline
made him an impossibility come November
would Bernie claim it when Hillary
swooped in with Michelle Obama
reconsider would chaos ensue I guess it
doesn't matter since we'll all be dead
from the Wuhan flu great question it
depends when Biden gets out so I think
there's a chance right now that and
that's what Bernie is banking on that
Biden just collapses if Bernie really
forces debates forces campaigning that
if Biden just collapses before the the
nomination let's assume he gets the
nomination and let's assume worst case
absolutely unthinkable scenario that
something happens to the guy the mental
decline continues or you know look we
are in the midst of a global pandemic
that affects specifically people in Joe
Biden's age group so you know it's an
ugly thing to think about but one does
have to consider these possibilities
then it would be up to the Democratic
Party we really don't know that would be
unprecedented territory in our political
era and so I think Hillary would
certainly want to sweep in I think that
Nancy Pelosi has left open this door I
think Maxine Waters has left open this
door that there would have to not for
themselves but that there would be
another candidate coming in no one has
really fully settled on Joe Biden yet I
know it's he's running away with the
delegate count so it's probably his but
listening to the way that the party
elites talk they're not so happy with
him so frankly even if he doesn't have a
health problem I wouldn't be surprised
if the Democrats tried to pull some
shenanigans anyway from Christina dear
mr. Noles I love your show thank you I'm
having quite a rough time recently I
discovered my boyfriend now ex cheated
on me
we were both conservative
Christiane's and quite frankly I do not
know how he claims to be such and then
be unfaithful but that's besides the
point that this said this said
ex-boyfriend of almost five years had
put many thoughts in my head seeds of
insecurities that I'm not good enough in
any sense I'm trying to put my trust in
God to help guide me on my journey of
healing do you have any advice Thanks
yes I do I have a lot of advice actually
I see a little bit of a problem in your
question which is you say you you don't
understand how your ex-boyfriend could
claim to be a Christian and yet commit
this sin but isn't it one of the keen
insights of Christianity that we all sin
all of us fall short of the glory of God
and none of us is righteous in ourselves
and and so it just seems to me of course
people sin doesn't excuse what your
boyfriend did doesn't mean you should
get back with him he sounds like a real
schmuck but I'm just saying the idea
that somebody would sin even something
as serious is cheating on your
girlfriend or something yeah of course
the man's heart is evil from the very
beginning as we learn from the story of
Noah right I mean we this is something
we see throughout throughout the Bible
and the Christianity affirms that at all
times the reason that your boyfriend
seems like a terrible boyfriend beyond
cheating on you probably even more more
egregiously than cheating on you it
depends the nature of that if he was
like going out every single night and
you know I had had this double life
that's even worse but the real problem
is you say he planted these seeds of
insecurity and he was kind of mean to
you and I mean that's that's the real
problem that that can't just be
explained away as well Andrew Klavan
says that every man is two drinks in a
wink away from burning down his life you
can't explain being a rotten guy who's
cruel to his girlfriend away with two
drinks in a wink so what I would do is
get rid of him he sounds like a terrible
boyfriend so he's done that's over
doesn't sound remorseful doesn't sound
like a good guy anyway maybe it was a
blessing in disguise that you found out
he was cheating on you so you could get
rid of him and and move on
Javed the ancient writer not Christian
he wrote a very famous work called the
cure for love I don't necessarily
recommend you take all of the advice
but a lot of it if I could sort of
sanitize oven it was get rid of all your
boyfriend's photos delete all his photos
get them out of your phone don't think
about him
start seeing other people often to had a
little more lurid advice than that but
you know go on some dates put yourself
out there and forget it make a clean
break and move on with your life and
you'll probably have a better life that
way from Mike hi Michael I'm in a sales
job which requires that I speak to
customers for most of the day as most
sales jobs do but I find that I stumble
over my words and overall have poor
verbal fluency as an actor and someone
who spends a lot of time speaking do you
have any advice for speaking more
clearly and less like Joe Biden thanks
for all that you do big fan yes I do
first slow down people get nervous
especially if you're working a sales job
and so they want to start speaking more
quickly but when you speak more quickly
first of all that's very off-putting and
it gets you more nervous as well because
you feel you're kind of losing the
audience that's the first thing I would
do slow down people prefer it when you
slow down when you say things slowly
they seem more emphatic and they seem
more persuasive the next thing to do is
get rid of ohms and O's and likes get
them out of your vocabulary it is going
to be very difficult you are going to
still get a few in there I get some in
there every single day and I've been
working on this for a decade but get
them at um like you know it is like
nails on a chalkboard to people and some
people do it constantly I mean I've
heard people start speaking and they'll
say uh so look the thing that I believe
is that we need to answer the question
directly and then it's a tick for them
they cannot stand silence but if you are
a public speaker silence is a very
helpful tool it allows you to give
weight to what you've just said it
allows you to give people space to think
about what you've just said and it
doesn't make you seem quite so nervous
that would be my advice at first then I
would memorize poetry I would maybe take
an acting class I would do things that
will just get-get that
muscle moving one of the tricks that
actors have you know they memorize
things very quickly and very well people
wonder how this is the key to it is just
muscle memory when you're memorizing
most people think you just read it in
your head and then you remember it no
you get it into your mouth and so your
mouth your muscles will remember how to
to say what you're saying they'll
they'll practice it just like any other
skill you will need some practice from
quarry how and when did you meet Ben
Shapiro Ben was actually one of the
first guys I met in LA I had just moved
out here years ago but now maybe six
years ago or something like that a
little more and one of the first dinners
I had was at Drew's house at Andrew
Klavan house and it was me drew Ben
another friend of ours and our wives and
at the time my girlfriend and it was
their first time I met him the only
place I knew him from was that viral
clip on Piers Morgan's show thought oh
you're Ben Shapiro I know that guy
and and it was love at first sight I
think mostly on Ben's part toward me was
just he fell in love he went gaga
afterward and here we are now from
William my question is regarding your
comments on the rally in front of the
Supreme Court where Rashida Talib was
yelling into the microphone she
mentioned not having sex and I think she
makes an excellent point
sex creates babies in the best way to
avoid not being ready for a child is to
wait until marriage if the left wants to
empower women why then do they not talk
more about women refusing sex and
pushing from marriage prior to
intercourse thank you kindly god bless
because the left doesn't really care
about women there will I care about any
of us any other groups they pretend to
care about however in their defense
I'll give the philosophical basis for it
which you see a little bit on the right
as well the philosophical basis for
leftism
is a hyper individualism I know that
seems crazy because leftism taken to its
logical conclusion brings a kind of
collectivism about where the individual
doesn't matter very much but it begins
with this hyper individualism I get to
do whatever I want at all times I the
individual in the basic unit of society
in Planned Parenthood v Casey Justice
Kennedy decided that people have a right
a constitutional human right to define
reality for them
selves I mean that's the kind of radical
individualism and so that expresses
itself in sex because sex is one of our
most basic and fundamental desires and
lusts and so any sexual choice any
sexual preference any sexual desire any
sexual act needs to be available to
people and then there will be
consequences of that and through a
radical individualism which we would
also call selfishness
you can even convince a mother to kill
her own child from Dillion dear Michael
when it comes to abortion we know that
the majority of all abortions are based
on inconveniences in a very very small
number are based on rape and or the
health of the mother baby or at risk my
question to you would you accept a new
law to allow abortions for rape and/or
the health of the mother and baby being
at risk while banning all the rest
nationwide thanks yeah sure if I could
get rid of 99% of abortions I would do
it but it wouldn't really work that way
because as has happened elsewhere the
rule about the health of the mother
would would be expanded to mean if the
mother feels inconvenienced and gets a
migraine because she doesn't want have a
kid then you're allowed to kill the baby
there are virtually no health conditions
where the cure is abortion even ectopic
pregnancy there is you can treat the
ectopic pregnancy without having the
explicit intention of killing the baby
this would be the rule of double effect
and we can get into that in a later
episode
so always these things are going to be
abused and they're going to just expand
abortion through the backdoor I would
much rather be honest about the issue of
abortion that's the bait we're having
right now but if you put a bill on my
desk and said you can right now today
get rid of 99% of abortions yeah of
course I would do it last question from
Charles to the great Michael Knowles
what insight do you have from Super
Tuesday results from states like Texas
where more voters showed up to vote for
Trump in the primary it than showed up
for the entire Democratic Party thanks
and have a blessed day this is the
untalked about fact of this primary
season the turnout to the primaries to
re nominate the incumbent Republican
president is through the roof it blows
historical precedent out of the
water great news for Republicans of
course the media aren't gonna report on
that but it shows you that Bernie's
turnout lower than expected youth
turnout lower than expected Joe Biden
has done significantly better than
Bernie Sanders so we do have to worry
about that a little bit but there is a
silent plurality at least I think it's a
silent majority of Americans who support
President Trump now if the election were
held two weeks ago I think Trump would
have won fifty eight states plus
Greenland plus American Samoa but now
we've got this coronavirus problem we've
got the Dow dropping thousands of points
we've got a bear market I mean it's a
whole new ball game here and so the
bigger threat I think is not from any of
the Democrats I think the bigger threat
is from that damned little virus that
came out of Wuhan all right that's our
show I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show see you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Winooski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen